- All right, this thing on?
There's the camera? Okay.
So this episode is about
how to make the ultimate--
(upbeat music)
Sure, there are great standalone
video chatting devices,
like the Facebook Portal,
or the Amazon Echo Show.
But you don't need to
spend money on those,
or leave the house to get one.
Step one: get an old tablet or phone.
If these old devices are slow,
reset the whole thing to factory settings
and install the latest operating system.
If the battery's old,
just keep it plugged in.
You can buy an extra-long charging cable
if you need some wiggle room.
10 feet, everyone, 10
feet of lightning cable.
Or get an extension cord.
You don't have an old tablet?
Buy a new one, like the lowest end iPad,
or a Samsung Galaxy Tab A.
Step two: make a homemade stand.
Stop propping up your
devices with random things
from around the house,
and instead use things
from around the house
that really work.
You could try the wire hanger method.
Fold like so.
Aha, okay, also gonna fold
this a little bit back.
All right, that's looking good.
And then, this is a little
lip for the iPad in the front.
Doesn't look like much, but check it out.
Or you could try the cardboard box method.
These days you wanna disinfect.
Measure a rectangle that's about
25 centimeters by 20 centimeters.
(cutting)
Then measure 11 centimeters across.
Then draw some diagonal lines, like so
and then do like so.
(upbeat music)
Just wanna make sure to get a
close shot here of my artwork.
Boom!
Or you could try the egg carton method.
Or you could try the Lego method,
which my toddler's very confused by.
The beauty of all of these
is you can place these
in different areas around the house.
Step three: install your
video chat software of choice.
My go to is Facetime,
which is already built in
to your iPad or iPhone, but
of course there's also Zoom,
Houseparty, Google Hangouts,
all of those apps still
worked on this 2012 iPad,
that only supports iOS10, though
some features were limited.
Doesn't matter, they all work
with this great new stand.
What just happened?
- It fell!
- Oh no.